a community divided
if the community has a faith-based ethos
then the school should reflect that
where religion clashes with the system
now is that
okay to be gay in multicultural
birmingham
it would be a massive step backwards in
education
to suddenly say we won't talk about
different types of families anymore
because it might upset some people
it's home time at anderton park primary
school and another protest is about to
start
these parents don't want their children
taught about same-sex relationships
it's a conflict between religion and
education
a deep divide between parents and the
school
demonstrations have been going on for
weeks
the mom on the megaphone rosina afsar
has two young
our children our children
the past was often difficult but monkey
would not give up
my son came home with some homework
when i opened up the book to help him do
his work it was a book
called the princess boy i think is which
was um
about a boy who wants to be a girl who
wants to wear dresses who wants to have
tea parties so basically like
transgender
and it was very much saying that it's
okay to be
that way which was alarming for me
they're saying that it's okay to be a
gay
it's okay to be gay in their beliefs and
they
what they believe in which we respect
because everybody's got actually how
they want to live
how they want their life we're not
imposing on them
but we feel that they are imposing on us
this school in birmingham is at the
epicentre of a row over relationships
education the head teacher is adamant
that nothing will change
despite protesters including her own
pupils
chanting for her to go
the issue is we live in a country we
live in a city where there are many
same-sex parents
and what we have to do with children is
to educate about
tolerance respect understanding that not
everybody's like me
not everybody's like my family not
everybody shares the beliefs i
i have or my family has
and that's okay that's that's
interesting fighting for their
children's rights
this is where the protests began four
miles away at parkfield community school
actually aggressively promoting them
giving it a positive spin and telling
people
that it is okay for you to be muslim and
for you to be gay
[Applause]
their anger is directed at andrew moffat
the school's assistant head teacher
who's openly gay and the author of a
programme of lessons called no outsiders
the classes include books about same-sex
parents
his work on equality has earned him an
nbe but he told me he recently received
a death threat
and now has to defend the classes to
parents at his own school
i want to make very clear that night
science is not sex education and never
has been and there's
there is there is no reference to sex to
the the sexual acts in no
outsiders there's no books where there's
bodies or
bedrooms or you know it's no outside
it's about community cohesion
the school has currently suspended the
lessons to stop the protests
talks between parents and teachers are
ongoing
but from september 2020 relationships
education is becoming compulsory in all
primary schools
and parents will not have the right to
withdraw their children
are we lucky that is what we're going to
do
this is a no outsiders lesson being
taught to four and five-year-olds
so our story is called mummy
mama and me mommy picks me
up up up mama
pours juice in my cup the school in
cheshire is one of thousands
already teaching that families come in
many forms mommy
gently combs my hair
mama rocks me in her chair
mommy packs a yummy snack
mama rides me on her back pop your hands
up if you spotted
any of the things that we said
we like to do with our family during the
discussion that follows
none of the children ask why there are
two mums in the story
none of the children have actually
noticed but if they were to we would
just discuss the fact that
um yes there are two mums in that family
but some of our families made
in different ways so we would then talk
about how their families are made up
danny is a gay dad whose daughter is a
pupil here
it gives people the freedom to be who
they are and
for my child to talk about her
dance he's concerned about protests
against the lessons in birmingham
it's kind of reversing all of the work
that's happened in the uk
for the lgbt community it's um
we've we've took massive steps with
making marriage legal
and and stuff like that so this really
is damaging and it's
um it's kind of backtracking the uk
but these parents are not backing down
inside the head teacher showed me the
form all parents signed when their
children started at the school
so this is all about our ethos there are
many things here
we believe in british values equality of
gender disability sexual orientation
religious
we always challenge stereotypical views
how do you teach about lgbt issues
so the main messages about lbgt are that
many families are different
one thing in the eyes of british law is
not better than something else
it may be in religious law so
religio some religious law may say it's
not okay in our religion for two men to
get married we also talk to children
about that
and so if we say if we talk about two
daddies or two mommies we always say
you know your mum and dad might think
something different that's okay talk
talk to them
but rosina is concerned her children
will end up
confused i'm a muslim i've got a
six-year-old and i've got a
four-year-old i don't teach my children
at home about religion let alone
anything else
all they know is that we're muslims i
don't teach them the nitty-gritty
because they're too young
to understand all that information i
don't teach them about
what is it what is what's a right what's
right and what's wrong in regards to
sexuality is it you know is it right or
is it wrong to be wanting to be a
gay or lesbian or if you're a boy you
can be we don't have that conversation
because i don't feel the need to have
that conversation
my children don't come to me and ask why
this certain way because they're not
exposed to it
at home they're not exposed to it and at
schools i didn't think they were exposed
to it
my concerns were what is being taught at
school
is it going to contradict with what i
believe or
what i wha wha or how i would be raising
my children
[Applause]
the protests are organized by her
brother shaquille
he doesn't have children at the school a
question of that you just said was i'm
not a parent here
that i think is just a a diversion
because
as a member of the community if there's
a if there's more than one person who's
concerned
i have a right to speak up as a british
citizen
he tries to tell us who we
uh
that this is this is an issue for the
parents their children
and the school should listen this is
amir ahmed
he's the link between this protest group
and the original demonstrations at
parkfield
he doesn't have children at either
school but has a personal reason for
getting involved
his son goes to nansen primary one of
the schools that was involved in the
so-called trojan horse scandal
in 2014 ofsted found evidence of strict
religious practices imposed by
some governors and staff in secular
schools in birmingham
i don't believe that they did anything
wrong and and i think
there simply wasn't enough transparency
and openness
in those investigations i mean during
traditional
21 schools were investigated i think
that's a shame on ofsted
and it was very prejudicial and i find
that offset are still very prejudicial
i i feel that there was gross injustice
done
definitely the the children's education
was devastated
and and uh it is actually reasons for
that
that you know i've i've made my an extra
effort
to to to spend time on this
this community is a religious community
you only have to walk around it to see
that
yet the the whole practically all the
schools around here are secular schools
why are they secular schools
the schools should reflect the
community's ethos
and if the community has a faith-based
ethos then
the schools should reflect that colin
diamond was a lead investigator into the
trojan horse scandal
he witnessed what happened when
religious values were forced into
schools
we saw some gender segregation
in assemblies in lessons we saw that in
some cases
girls were discouraged from
participating in certain
sporting activities worship became a
more
prominent part of the school day
many people within the community still
never
really fully understood what happened
back in 2014
and 2015 and now
in 2019 we've had a
whole set of issues emerged around
teaching of relationships and sex
education
it's almost as if it's kind of rekindled
what was happening back in 2014
concern has spread beyond birmingham
[Music]
this footage posted on social media
shows a meeting in manchester
where teaching about lgbt relationships
was described as their trojan horse
teachers are seeing evidence of an
organized campaign across the country
what have we got here so what we've got
here is a selection of posters that are
appearing in schools communities so
encouragement for parents to go along to
meetings at which the misinformation is
being sewn throughout the community
letters from parents many of them
downloaded templates from protest
websites are being sent into schools
we've got reports of over 50 schools now
um in seven different local authorities
that have received in these letters
both within the muslim community but
also in in christian
you know faith schools uh church of
england schools for example
and on a number of letters which are
more personalized uh quite some
threatening uh letters and
correspondence those who have had to
personally reconcile their faith with
their
sexuality say it can be done all these
protests
to me growing through the era of the 70s
and 80s
it is harking back you know so many
years when we should be looking forward
and saying you know whether you're lgbt
or muslim it's okay we accept you for
who you are
there are strong feelings on both sides
we want somebody
to come and at least listen to us how to
reconcile
religion and education it is okay to be
getting british law
and that's been the case for many many
years
it's a row over the most emotive of
issues how best to prepare children for
life in modern britain
[Music]